machine à coudre pistolet à colle et
ciseaux des outils que ses enfants
utilisent parfois pour la première fois
avec l'aide d'une costumière ils
apprennent à créer leur propre
déguisements les filles décident leurs
robes de princesse j'ai voulu faire ton
costume que des fleurs et à de deux
couleurs bleu et rouge
j'aime bien les français j'aime bien
soin du bricolage je voulais faire ce
coup là parce que j'aime ça et ce soir
ça faisait bien de faire du boulot euros
après du rocher c'est la première fois
aussi utiliser la machine est variable
et papier crépon et tissus deviendront
une robe agrémentée de fleurs du côté
garçons célian c'est en sera un robot il
s'applique à coller les cheveux sur son
casque en carton ondulé un apprentissage
des différents matériaux et surtout de
l'autonomie de la manipulation de la
manipulation encore de la manipulation
et surtout des coupes et piqué la
machine ça et se pique à la machine le
papier crépon donc ça aussi c'est
important que les enfants puissent le
faire il ya une partie où j'abandonne
une fois qu'ils ont une petite
initiation ils se repèrent vite les
enfants suis pas inquiète
point d'orgue de ce stage de quatre
jours un défilé pour dévoiler son
costume aux parents d'autres ateliers
sont proposés par guyancourt durant
toutes les vacances